les confessions a fait rêver c'est
vraiment des confessions a baissé de
résoudre un problème c'est qu'à ouvrir
aux yeux oui je sais ça voilà c'est quoi
vos bois nous et c'est vrai mais je dois
vraiment à vouloir changer mais parce
que cyril me m'a donné un vrai complexe
maintenant je suis j'ai eu cette viper
bien ouais je dois arriver alors oui
laure nettoie les yeux grands ouverts ça
tirait pas du tout au tout les jours ça
ne va pas dans la vie d'avoir faut pas
être complexé par les autres très bien
et en plus on s'assume et à la con et ça
fait ça fait votre charme déjà bien sûr
s anté yeux comme ça tu vas peut-être
pas pécho fait différent ah bon non mais
je te le dis est vrai il faut dire que
tu as tu as eu un très grand succès avec
ces yeux là les chances pas je vais te
dire voilà vous c'est quoi votre
complexe parce que vous êtes sûrs et
baby non plus moi c'est juste moi c'est
le sens de la répartie je n'ai aucun
franchement je suis nul n'aurait pas
renié
ouais qu'est ce que j'ai fait ici c'est
pas possible vous avez en trop mais ça
fait dix ans qu'ils me traîne comme un
boulet le malheureux tu n'es pas là pour
tirer parti donc là pour ta gentillesse
merci
[Applaudissements]
oui fonds soit qui tu parles et la perse
personnes leur nature y est
naturellement tenté jeanne d'arc alors
jean michel maire c'est quoi vous et moi
je provoque h ladoux genre plus tôt l'un
demain et que je ne fais jamais ah ouais
ça je le fais pas deux et j'ai envie de
dire et pourquoi pas s'arrête pose pas
de problème parce que je ne fais rien
mon cher jean michel parent je vous
connais un petit peu nous procrastiner
pas avec les femmes n'est ce pas
d'ailleurs ça nous promet je suis
instable hillary talent passionnel et je
me lasse et quand on vous donne un
rendez vous vous y allez donc penser le
percepteur s'est pas rangé cabine sans
rendez vous c'est du coach quoi cette
histoire de rendez vous là je re tête la
ricoh quand il a un rencard avec une
nanard ne dites par pète devant castaldi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
va appliquer comme on disait jadis ou
comme dirait cyril hanouna quand il veut
pécho une nana et qu'il a un rendez vous
ils imaginent demain
donc quand tu l'as au percepteur qui lui
demande de régler ses impôts il y va
aussi voilà un courrier le mali mais
c'est par cette voie là mais voilà les
chauffer dans une caméra cachée pour la
grande brasserie ouais je sais je me
rappelle qu'à l'initiative de syrie mais
parce qu on se connaît depuis tellement
longtemps entre les deux jamais n'ont
donc je me suis dit
[Rires]
comme c'est quoi bouger chez moi comme
vous j'ai un énorme complexe c'est quoi
en fait je stagnais lamentablement au
tennis très très complexée par mon
revers et bien quand même donné alors
jeune et il faut faire du hockey sur
gazon je crois qu'elle parle des
déplacements ouais nous faire chier ou
trop près ou trop loin de la balle et
c'est vrai ça me permet de vous donner
quelques cours j'aimerais bien battu
djokovic c'était vous ont créé par magie
grand il me semble c'est pas besoin de
cours de votre part moi me semble
surtout que tu aimerais bien bas avec
plaisir géraldine ça me fera très
plaisir parce qu'on est instinctif sur
le court je sens voilà vous êtes vous
pas technique mais vous avez plus jeune
fils un très beau dépassement qui vous
attendent toujours au badminton
[Rires]
j'ai vu hamilton s'est soustrait
badminton mais chaque fois une dame âgée
qui là bas il ya vous et moi il ya plein
de gens y compris le champion de france
1 voix il a mené le mois très bien mené
le moi je vais jouer contre lui dites
moi qui dis c'est quoi vous moi c'est
mon poids je vois et j'entends pour
beaucoup d'émissions avec des rondes
bien sûr je peux sentir mal et ce qui y
perd important ça c'est aussi mon boulot
de journaliste c'est ce que je disais à
benjamin c'est hyper important de
s'assumer et j'en sais quelque chose
parce que moi quand j'ai des kilos en
trop il m'en reste encore à peine ça
monte ça m'ennuie mais il faut s'assumer
et vous mettre en valeur pour sa mrc
mais physiquement il faut s'aimer alors
non mais ce que manifestement et ça
c'est simon c'est quand on a son visage
on se fout de son poids du toit landed
il faut insulter parce que si vous vous
aimez pas physiquement si vous ne vous
aimez pas dans la tête des bons jours
mais elle est maintenant vous avez
d'elle mais elle est magnifique et la
pâte filo ayez confiance voilà et
sélectif et sciences noyau pas rayonnant
on va parler de c'est mon choix je veux
rien changer ses réponses 3 mai prochain
coach
non non j'ai rien moi j'ai pas de bail à
mesure des besoins des mre changé c'est
nous les chroniques la question c'est
quelles sont les problèmes qui vous
gâchent la vie à part une personne vous
de voir de qui il s'agit